>>Teacher: Welcome, all.
As of today, April 27, senior
sign-in day, over 95 percent
of the seniors have been accepted to
at least 2 colleges and universities.
>>Narrator: A core
principle of YES Prep is
that every student will
attend and succeed in college.
>>Mark: We have this high expectation
that all kids go to college,
but we don't leave it there.
We kind of backwards-plan from there:
Here are the things that we need
to do in order to make sure
that kids are going to be ready.
>>Narrator: YES Prep's
college-bound culture is built
on three key components: an
environment of expectation...
>>Teacher: So now let me
see your college list.
>>Narrator: ...a college-prep
seminar class...
>>Guide: And this is the bookstore.
We can take a look in there.
>>Narrator: ...and
college-campus visits,
where students experience the
look and feel of a college.
>>Guide: Now we'll go to the gym.
There is fitness classes here...
>>Narrator: The promise of
a college education begins
with a home visit and
contract-signing.
>>Chris: The home visits are when
we go through the contract with them
and their parents and we talk about,
"This is what it means
to be a student at YES."
>>Teacher: Good to meet you.
I'm going to give you a copy of...
>>Chris: The contract is
good because it's symbolic.
What we want parents to understand is
that this has got to
be a team effort.
This is a three-legged stool.
It's us; it's your kid; and it's you.
And if we work together for the
next seven years, your kid's going
to be able to go to any
college they want to.
>>Teacher: And then sign under
the "student signature," please.
>>Chad: By the time the students get
to 11th grade they've been talking
about college since the 6th
grade, and they've got homerooms
that are named after colleges
and people are asking them
where they want to go to college,
and even though they
really don't have any idea--
and they shouldn't necessarily
have any idea at that point--
they at least know that
they want to go to college
and they're all focused on that.
>>Student: But you can
apply as soon as possible
into August through October.
>>Narrator: In the
college-prep seminar class,
juniors spend a year learning how
to select and apply to colleges.
>>Chad: It's basically a
College Prep 101-type class,
so a lot of SAT/ACT prep.
We take the students through what the
admissions process will look like,
focus on building their
college lists.
We'll talk about applications.
We talk about financial
aid, scholarships,
so that when it becomes
college-application season
that they're ready to go.
>>"Areas of Study."
Click on that.
>>One of the benefits of the
extended day is that we have
that extra two hours per day
that most schools don't have,
and it allows you to
do something like this,
where the students can come in every
day, and it's valuable not only
for the time that they get but also
the relationships that are built
between the students and
the college counselors,
just because it would
be impossible for us
to truly recommend the right schools
and to put them in the right position
if we didn't really get to know them.
>>Teacher: All right, well,
welcome to the University
of St. Thomas, everyone.
>>Narrator: To help students get a
sense of college life, YES takes them
on field trips to a
variety of campuses.
>>Mark: Over the course of
a student's history at YES,
that student's going to see 20 to 25
schools, actually go to the campus
and be on that campus
and meet students
and meet professors on that campus.
>>Guide: What do you
all think so far?
>>Student: I think I like that
it's in the center of Houston.
>>Chad: It's just exposure.
So much of finding your fit and sort
of picturing yourself on campus has
to do with actually getting on
the campus and being able to see
for yourself, and so we're able to
hold classes on a college campus
and then tie that in with an
information session and a tour...
>>Guide: Right here is the lounge.
>>Chad: ...so they can really
picture themselves there and try
to get a sense as to
what it might be like.
>>Teacher: And over 90 percent
of this year's graduates
are first-generation
college-bound students.
>>All: [cheers]
>>Craig: Every year the
seniors get together
and they sign their acceptance
letters to college, all at one time,
in front of their friends and
their family in a huge auditorium.
>>Diana: Good afternoon.
My name is Diana Rivera, and this
fall I will be attending Columbia
University in the city of New York.
>>All: [cheers]
>>Craig: I remember signing my
acceptance letter on a kitchen table,
and I think maybe my mom
walked by while I did.
>>Student: And this fall I'll be
attending Texas A&M University.
>>Craig: This is 100 times bigger,
and it means so much to these kids.
>>Student: ...where I'll be
majoring in biomedical engineering.
>>Craig: And when our kids
walk across that stage
and they sign those letters...
>>Nelson: Good afternoon.
My name is Nelson Mendoza and
this fall I will be attending
Yale University.
>>All: [cheers]
>>Craig: ...it's exactly
what we've been working
for for the past eight years.
>>Narrator: For more
information about what works
in public education,
go to edutopia.org.